All right, let's go to our color from the
five one nine area code.
Who's calling today from five one nine.
Hi David, this is Jesse.
Hey Jesse, what's going on?
Not too much.
I'm a huge fan of your show and I really appreciate
you having your life.
Thank you.
Um, I just have two questions for you.
Uh, the one is, do you think the left is giving
their power away by not giving enough empathy
to people on the right?
Maybe even Donald Trump, you know, kind of
dehumanizing him and being sort of vicious
and losing sight of, you know, the fact that
he's just a person.
And B,
I don't know.
Well, hold on, let's take it one at a time.
How is the left dehumanizing Trump?
I see a lot more dehumanization coming from
Trump than to Trump.
Oh, absolutely.
So what I'm saying, like I'm a progressive
and that's one of the reasons why I've watched
your show because you're very balanced in
your judgments, but you also, um, are kind
of a lefty electing himself, it seems like.
So what I'm saying is even though we have
people who do terrible things, at the end
of the day, when we stop treating them like
people and start treating them like monsters,
it almost gives them more power in a sense.
Would you agree with that?
I think that there are circumstances in which
that's true.
Yeah.
And it kind of leads into my second question
is do you think the left, um, and some of
the, uh, public speakers on the left, like
even nuts or, uh, talk show host some, uh,
what have you, like Stephen Colbert evangelize
Trump's brand more than they, uh, take them
down in a sense?
You mean inadvertently?
Yeah.
So I noticed that, um, ever since Donald Trump
started running for presidency, uh, Steven
Cole bear can't help but discuss Trump and
this seems like a widespread thing on the
left.
Yeah.
And my concern, I live in Canada by the way,
so I'm just kind of watching everything unfold.
Um, my concern is that by always focusing
on him and making him a monster, not kind
of bringing it down to a human level.
And if they don't stop talking about him,
they're actually evangelizing.
I dunno.
I mean, listen, you can make the case that
if you just, if media literally pays no attention
to someone, that person becomes no one because
they go away.
Trump is the president of the United States.
He would still be doing things even if people
didn't pay attention.
And people wouldn't be aware of the things
that he is doing, which are objectively bad.
So I understand the point you're trying to
make.
I think it's more about finding a balance.
But no, I have no particular reason to think
that someone like Stephen Colbert has actually
evangelizing for Trumpism.
Okay.
Um, well thank you so much, uh, for your time
today.
I really appreciate it.
All right, Jesse, appreciate the phone call.
Thank you so much.